hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to twelve grapes a game
where you play as an alien and try to
eat humans great way to start off the
day for me we must complete our mission
before the year ends if we are to
survive and avoid the enemy and eat 12
humans eelain's with negative thoughts
and memories might hurt you use the mind
reading equipment in order to find the
tasty ones otherwise the positive ones
who are really happy in life use the
arrow keys or the WASD to fly around
press e to duck your prey oh boy this is
going to be a fun game I can already
tell but it was featured on gamejolt
which I found many an indie game to play
so here we go
why not uh oh I literally have an
earthbound alien here we go you hey hey
hey hey hey whoa whoa hey whoa whoa oh
my god this is actually hard to control
give me you be a positive I'd like to
have some more fun and try to be hit
okay this guy's Skye's little saddle
I'll let him go he's had a rough day you
know I don't wanna I'm gonna bother him
too much with anything else I gotta be
careful not to abduct the same guy that
I just picked up I had a huge success on
my personal projects congratulations you
get eaten Oh congratulations on doing so
good on nine oh grad that was actually
really bloody and horrible so the enemy
is actually just more humans more humans
that are trying not to let their fellow
humans get eaten I have a terrible I
didn't work hard enough making games
this at the creator of the game it's his
name David white or is that another game
developer that I don't know I feel so
bad right now
it's okay you worked hard enough in my
mind don't mind me Oh ah ow ow okay ah
really hard to get out okay I'm not good
at this game
I gotta like using another button to
press e because I need all of my fingers
to maneuver around away from the bullets
okay I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to do this
all right even if lots of things went
wrong I don't regret a thing hey that's
a positive healthy way of looking at
things John Davis congratulations you
get eaten mmm
okay did that that hurt me you got to be
kidding that hurt me
where did they just hit me with the
bullet I don't know if that's actually
what happened I had two little free time
well all right Kevin Smith if you're
another developer of the game I feel bad
but not that bad I didn't get to spend
much time with my group all worries yeah
everyone's so sad maybe that's like a
commentary on humanity today I don't
know if I picked this guy up I had
totally goddamn it Kevin Smith I know I
didn't want to eat him Oh Kevin Smith
blew my ship up with his sadness ha ha
ha gay so silly also why is Christmas
music playing I just realized that
there's Christmas music playing I
couldn't spend much time with my friends
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
god I have to eat positive people only
sad people are gonna be left I'd like to
be able to earn enough money with my
drawings is that sad or happy I don't
know I'm gonna eat you it doesn't sound
sad Hey it wasn't that sad okay all
right this is it those kind of positive
you wants to be able to make a living
doing god dammit with your free time kit
out here it's Christmas I gotta eat
people this
Oh God ah okay all right it actually is
really hard to maneuver around and try
to abduct people at the same time I'd
like to speak more spontaneous honest
and just be myself wrote about that's a
positive attitude oh yeah get in my
belly god damn it I'm not gonna be able
to win this I'm gonna win this
oh I'm not gonna win this I wasn't
strong enough dude has to focus and
finish my final group god everyone is so
sad to be happy everybody be eaten by
aliens and be happy maybe I should have
tried harder to find a job ah ha ha ha
everyone so sad although some of these I
don't know if they're like super sad I
wasn't able to show me oh it's so sad
all of these are sad head my son was
born ah ha ha ha I have to eat chip
that's happy he ah this game is terrible
this game is a conundrum this game oh
man there's a huge catch-22 here I wish
I would publish a game that would become
a great hit so I get some money or a new
job sounds like a positive attitude yeah
it was good job ambition I guess also
qualifies as positive attitude I was on
the verge of moving to London with my
girlfriend when she decided to put an
end to our relationship but I have to re
plan my future once again ok that's not
positive that's that's bad I'm sorry I'm
sorry about how about this guy he might
be a tasty morsel not a good year my
grandma died and I became unemployed ok
I'd like to have more fun try to be
happier that's a positive attitude you
won't have a chance to do that now hmm
and a huge success on my personal
project congratulations get eaten like a
grape I guess this game is called 12
grapes for some reason I guess because
humans are like tasty goddamnit do some
of you guys think that I'm an alien and
I want you all to have a positive
attitude because I've actually what a
harvest should eat you not not true at
all Merry Christmas
friend of mine god Jill after a long
time you won't be able to see him hmm
this guy was trying to avoid me I'd like
to make more games draw more stuff and
travel to new places well all of those
wants and desires it's too late now
Oh God what is it with me in playing
these simple looking games that have
such deeper meanings I regret nothing
do you regret this ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha
I should have been more authentic since
the beginning the positive attitude I
had to live in Madrid for a whole year
is that bad or good people in Madrid
I've heard that it's a beautiful city if
this hurts me
well then too bad
watch madrid's bad that's good
never enough free time to dedicate to
personal prod I always I think Madrid is
good maybe maybe Madrid's justice giant
hellhole that no one escapes from maybe
I should how God you again also many
people that need to find a job they got
you God Michael we get out of here I'm
done with your bull I know I've seen way
worse problems than what you have oh I
should've tried to be god damn it my
Robert will him get out of here where's
all the Babel you you you you come here
come here come here come here
thanks for standing still I made up with
a friend hadn't spoken to for years
congratulations sir your brother Robert
hmm
where are all the people oh god dammit I
can't lose now not now not now I got too
much regret oh all frak alack if I lose
it now I'm gonna be so pissed at myself
ah I probably could have just eaten
someone with bad memories at this point
and I would have been fine
recurring illness made daily routine
hard to do and make many plans
impossible that's a new one that's a new
level of sad you come here you better be
tasty damn it
become unemployed going to the agency
just to wait oh okay
this year I finally released the game
I'd been working on for two years it
wasn't a commercial success but
finishing its development feels great
yes finally someone I can devour someone
who's had a good experience I did it 12
of 12 that took longer than I thought
congratulations on completing your
mission but there's something important
we haven't told you every time you read
someone's mind you were actually reading
reading actual memories from real people
who submitted them through an online
platform I guess you weren't expecting
that ah I ate the good people I hate
them God terrible contributors okay
great Oh hmm that's the end of the game
I guess gasps its supportable why do I
do this why do I play games that are
intentionally mind like blowy and my I
can't word at the moment but either way
there's a lot of fun and really
interesting to think about it the only
people that I have to eat it are
positive that only leaves people with
bad experiences left in the world so
just I hope you're having a good day I
really hope you do like I want you to go
out there and just you know believe in
yourself because I do it may sound
cliche whenever I say that but I don't
care I'm gonna say it anyway you know I
do believe in you guys and I believe in
myself and I want you to be able to
pursue what you want to do like don't
live with regret it's important not to
because aliens will come and leave you
alone and not eat you and God everyone
wants to be eaten by an alien don't take
that the wrong way
got you your minds in the gutter but god
damn it I love you thank you again
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
what are you doing that bus stopped at
me
stop it grille version of me stop
humping that bus